tudying languages is a privilege. When you analyze
language and everyday speech you start to realize
that there is an astonishing amount of wonder
in this system that we take for granted.
Linguists questioned the obvious, which
is language, and got answers that forever
changed mankind’s understanding of Language
and human nature. In this article, you will
see what linguists know that is not so evident
to other people. So let’s see what we’ve got.
We all speak one language.
One of the main discoveries of modern linguistics
is that it made us aware that all the languages
we speak are similar in astonishing respects;
they manifest the same pattern, follow the same
rules, they are learnt in exactly the same way,
and that all the differences are only superficial.
So, in a sense we all speak the same language.
This was captured by Chomsky in an excellent
metaphor in an excellent book of his titled
Language and Mind in which he
says that if a Martian scientist,
somebody with a different kind of intelligence,
were to study the world’s languages,
he would conclude that they are all dialects
of a single language embodying a “universal
grammar” reflecting a hardwired, genetically
determined linguistic module inherent in the
human brain. A great deal of theories complied
a huge base of evidence from topologically
different languages to show that this is
indeed the case. I will mention, in passing,
one of probably the main arguments used to
prove this. Take a child that was born in China,
and have him raised in Saudi Arabia
and he’ll grow up speaking Arabic.
What does that say to you? It says that a
human child is hardwired to learn any language
and that all human languages, say Mandarin and
Arabic in this case are fundamentally the same,
if they weren’t, the task of child to learn any
language would be impossible. This has massive
implications, the greatest of which is that all
the 7000 human languages have the same source
and that every language spoken today evolved
from the same great-great…great-grandmother
tongue, the first language of homo sapiens.
Another implication is that if a Martian would fly
past our planet, he would hear Japanese and Ojibwe
like we hear British and American English.
anguage change is natural:
People so soften combat language
change and are feared by it. Linguists know that
natural language change is not bad for a language.
Adopting loan words from other languages,
losing inflection, cases, genders, articles
and formerly distinct sounds…This happens in
all languages and is nothing to worry about.
For a linguist, it’s an interesting phenomenon,
worth analyzing. For some people it’s proof for
the demise of language, the end of civilized
culture and the beginning of the dying of the
proper language. But languages constantly change
and this is certainly not how languages die.
Too many people fear language change. Many people
think that if we don’t attempt to regulate the
“correct” way of speaking — from spelling to
pronunciation to word choice — then we will all
plunge into anarchy or some other misfortune.
It’s a sham. Language constantly evolves,
and even those political/cultural
elites who claim to use it “correctly”
fail to do so themselves; this is why you find
split infinitives in written opinions of the
U.S. Supreme Court, for example. (And even those
who fancy themselves guardians of The Correct
Way of Speaking can’t even agree on whether split
infinitives are kosher). Societies rise and fall,
but not because too many people started to say
“ain’t” when they should have said “isn’t.”
There are no bad grammars:
One of the things you know when you start
studying languages is that you realize how stupid
is the claim that says there are bad grammars.
Linguists know that all dialects,
even those considered “bad grammar”
by many people, are as fully formed
and rule-bound as any other language.
Someone who uses Appalachian dialect
or African American Vernacular English
(to use two U.S. examples), is not simply ignorant
of grammatical rules taught in school, or speaking
“sloppily.” They are following a different set
of rules, which are consistent within their own
dialect. Sometimes the linguistic complexity
of languages associated with underprivileged
societies and that we call bad grammars far
exceeds that of modern and privileged societies.
William Labov in fact analyzed African American
Vernacular English and showed us that it is a
beautiful language with a sophisticated structure
and has many features that Standard English lacks.
Read more about this is Labov’s own book titled
Language in the inner city: Studies in the Black
English Vernacular. You can get it [here].
There are monolingual linguists:
I don’t know how to stress this further. Being a
linguist does not equal being a polyglot. While it
is true that linguists study all languages, this
does not mean that they engage in learning them.
They only study them to test certain hypotheses
related to how language works. Linguists know that
there are monolingual linguists, there are even
linguists who advise against learning languages.
Seriously, people should stop using “linguist”
and “polyglot” or “language lover” synonymously.
The surest way to annoy a linguist is to
ask: “so how many languages do you speak?”
Read about what linguists do [here].
Language is fractal:
Linguists know that you really can’t
fully describe any human language.
It seems to be impossible to produce enough rules
to fully describe any natural language. You always
find that there are valid expressions that your
rules forbid and invalid expressions that your
rules permit. (That’s what we mean when we
say “all grammars leak.”) Of course you can
create new rules to cover those exceptions, but
teams have spent decades at this without closing
all the holes–despite creating tens of thousands
of rules. This is one reason linguists have
trouble taking grammar “prescriptivists”
seriously; we know that no description of
grammar small enough to fit in a single volume
can be anything more than a set of guidelines.
Linguists know that everybody who speaks one
language, can learn others, if they want to.
The mathematics behind linguistics (e.g. Automata
Theory and Chomsky’s hierarchy of languages),
indicate that an astonishing amount of
intelligence is required to become a monoglot.
The more we study computational
linguistics and automata theory,
the more we understand this.
The simplest theoretical machine that
could accurately parse a human language and
map to meanings, would be incredibly complex.
Surprisingly, the amount of complexity one
must add in order to parse a second language
is almost negligible. In other words, there is
no real difference in the intelligence necessary
to become a monoglot or a polyglot.
Perceived differences in difficulty have more
to do with learning as an adult vs. as a child
(during the critical period), and with enjoyment
of learning and willingness to work.
I’m sure linguists know so much more than
can be said in a blog post. Linguists
changed our perceptions about language,
changed the way we regard minority languages,
and most importantly linguists made us aware that
no language is inferior. Join the bandwagon to
recognize the efforts of linguists by subscribing
by email and sharing the video. Thank you very
much for reading. I will see you in my next video.